bonsoir alexandre langlois et merci
d'être en direct avec nous en juin
dernier vous vous êtes donc que déclarer
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 aujourd'hui vous venez de
déposer donc avec vos avocats un recours
en référé au tribunal administratif de
paris donc à l'encontre du scs avoue
dénoncé le mode de calcul du temps de
parole des candidats qui provoquerait
selon vous des inégalités entre les
aspirants à l'elysée ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer le sens de notre démarche
bonsoir alors oui effectivement
le temps de parole des candidats est
calculé par rapport à plusieurs choses
des résultats aux dernières élections et
également à leurs résultats dans les
sondages mais du coup les sondages y
arrive aucune règle qui permet de savoir
comment les sondages sont faits et qui
encadrent ces deux qui peut y rentrer
dans les sondages donc la demande
qu'elle fait au csa c'est de clarifier
ses règles parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons quand même à quelque chose d'assez
ironique et amusant les sondages donnent
gagnant de ce fait à m au second tour de
la présidentielle
deux personnes qui ne sont pas encore
officiellement candidat donc en fait il
ya une orientation médiatique des par
les sondages et pour contrer ça en
demande des règles toutes simples parce
que le conseil constitutionnel avait dit
que il était garant du pluralisme
du pluralisme et que le pluralisme était
une garantie de la démocratie et que
justement ça débouche sur la sincérité
du scrutin si les gens n'ont pas toutes
les informations pour pouvoir aller
voter pour pouvoir trouver les
parrainages ça fausse le scrutin
également comme il ya un vide juridique
on a également saisi le premier ministre
pour lui demander en urgence de
clarifier les règles est justement de
décrire des règles sur ce sujet là soit
par décret soit par une loi en urgence
pour que justement ce vide juridique qui
profite à des personnes qui sont auto
désignés se termine par quelque chose de
légal c'est finalement les ce qu'on
retrouve dans les uns dans l'est dans
les sondages ce sont les personnes que
l'on voit les plus le plus sur le
plateau sur les plateaux de télévision
est ce que vous vous estimez que ça
biaise le débat savièse le jeu de cette
élection présidentielle va effectivement
pour expliquer quelque chose pour gagner
des électeurs pour gagner des soutiens
si les gens ne vous connaissent pas vous
ne pouvez effectivement pas propagé vos
idées et donc effectivement ça participe
pas au débat démocratique on a un
exemple du genre je suis passé dans une
sur ces 8 le lendemain j'ai eu des coups
de téléphone de plusieurs personnes qui
disaient on savait pas que vous étiez
candidat ça nous intéresse on veut vous
soutenir donc il ya vraiment un rôle de
cause à effet est pas le point le
système médiatique en tous les cas pour
nous on s'enferme sur des sondages qui
peut faire plaisir qui peut faire les
choses mais il ya déjà plus de 36
candidats déclarés ce qui est déjà deux
fois moins qu'en 2017 mais donc ça
permettrait aussi d'avoir le sonder les
gens réellement là on a l'impression
qu'en fait il ya un filtre médiatique on
ne compte dans les commandes de sondages
qui disent voilà ce qu'on va proposer
aux français et vous n'aurez le choix
que nous ce qu'on aurait sur ce qu'on a
décidé dans la démocratie ce n'est pas
ça la démocratie c'est les électeurs qui
doivent décider doit pas y avoir de
filtre entre eux et les candidats
vous êtes officiellement candidat ce
n'est pas le cas d'eric zemmour et vous
lisiez tout à l'heure finalement est-ce
que ce n'est pas injuste qu'ils soient
omniprésents sur dans les médias alors
que vous vous y trouvons beaucoup plus
rarement
à juste c'est pas cette question là pour
le moment il n'ya pas d'empêchement
légale à cette décision va ya un
paradoxe est que le csa avait voulu que
de limiter son temps de parole qui est
dû le faire démissionner de son poste a
priori sans raison parce qu'il n'était
pas candidat et mettant le voit autant
que jamais dans toutes les couvertures
de médias il est encore plus omniprésent
dans les médias donc pendant légalement
rien ne s'y oppose après sinon ça ne
semble pas légitime c'est pour ça qu'on
demande que la légitimité soit cadré par
quelque chose de légal et c'est ça ou
rien ce flou juridique est aujourd'hui
par exemple monsieur zemmour continuer
de pouvoir bénéficier
sans pour autant être candidat ce qui
pose quand même difficulté est ce que
vous estimez être boycottée par les
médias vous êtes souvent invitée sur des
plateaux télé
ça dépend des moments on a eu la chance
qu'on a lancé la campagne d'avoir
quelques une petite couverture
médiatique de quelques journaux de rt
france qui étaient présents après le
boycott c'est des fois aussi la
méconnaissance parce que les médias
aussi sur certains se disent qu'est ce
qui va être vendeur qu'est ce qui ne va
pas être vendeur et bas du c'est de
savoir comment on peut faire des choses
je sais que du temps où j'étais
syndicaliste aussi encore d'ailleurs est
encore policiers mais on est et on a été
boycottée par les médias sur demande à
priori gouvernementale certains
journalistes ne nous l'ont dit en disant
qu'à écouter voilà comme vous dérange et
robin les médias on a eu un choix soit
de plus vous invitez soit plus avoir les
informations officielles ce qui pose une
question c'est j'en veux pas aux médias
pour le coup là j'en veux à des
consignes politiques pour limiter la
parole dans une démocratie on ne devrait
pas limiter la parole encore moi en ce
jour d'hommage à sa belle pub merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions sur ce
recours que vous avez donc déposé
alexandre lavoie merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous